[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show i'm very
excited about this we're going to be
talking about a whole slew of different
topics a wide spectrum of my personal
interests but not expertise my guest
today is isabel benke let me spell that
for you
per her twitter handle at isabel
i-s-a-b-e-l last name
b-e-h-n-c-k-e isabel is a field
primatologist and applied evolutionary
ethologist who studies social behavior
in animals that includes us humans to
understand our urgent challenges with
each other and the planet isabel grew up
at the foothills of the andes mountains
in chile where she developed a lifelong
love for nature and wildness as well as
culture in the arts an explorer
scientist she is the first south
american to follow great apes in the
wild of africa
she walked more than 3 000 kilometers
for us yanks that's roughly 1 864 miles
quite a few in the jungles of congo for
her field research observing the social
lives of wild bonobo apes who together
with chimpanzees are our closest living
relatives isabelle documented how
bonobos play freely in nature and has
extended this research to show how human
apes play
at burning man for instance other
festivals and in everyday life isabel
has observed how play is at the root of
creativity social bonding and healthy
development findings that have relevance
in education innovation complex risk
assessment freedom and many many other
places isabel we'll see how i can screw
up these titles and
of course degrees which is always a
challenge isabel holds a
bachelor's of science in zoology and a
masters of science in nature
conservation both from university
college london
a master of philosophy an m phil in
human evolution from cambridge
university and a phd although i think
it's a doctor dr phil that's not dr phil
as in the daytime show host something
like that phd in evolutionary
anthropology from oxford university she
has won several distinctions for her
public communication and knowledge
integration which ranges in format from
ted which was also most recently on the
grand stage so congratulations for that
wired the un bbc where i think she won
or was nominated is having one of the
most interesting interviews of 2020 i
think she ranked number three and nat
geo to rural schools in patagonia and
traveling buses of school children in
cargo she is a senior fellow of the
grueter institute a ted fellow and
currently advises the chilean government
working on long-term strategies in
science technology innovation and
knowledge for chile's president she can
be found in chile and new york city you
can find her on twitter like i mentioned
at isabellebenky and on instagram isabel
underscore benkei b-e-h-n-c-k-e
now we can get into it isabel nice to
see you
hello tim very nice to see you
so we're going to bounce all over the
place
and we've met before
so i am excited to dig into all sorts of
different stories
all sorts of background
and
cover a lot of things that we have not
talked about so let's start with
bako and jiro who are bako and jiro and
maybe we could paint a picture for us
i love this question
it was august 2010
ambako and jiro
are two males and they were
one of them was kicking the other in the
nuts
where i like to start all my interviews
[Laughter]
gently
gently there was no harm done and don't
do this at home
i should have started saying that
there was also
some biting
and
other forms
of physical touch
which may have looked to an untrained
eye like fighting
but bacon jiro were not fighting they
were playing
uh and back on jira were in the depths
of the jungles in congo
and they
are they were
not humans but
bonobo males
and this observation of these two males
playing
was to me really extraordinary because
let me give you some context
after the
uh
the kicking in the nuts comment
uh
bonobos are
together with chimpanzees our living
closest relatives
and we have many other evolutionary
relatives but they're dead they're
extinct
so
for us primatologists it's really
amazing to be able to observe the
naturally occurring behavior of apes in
the wild
it's a difficult for many reasons but
but they are still
some alive which is great
and i was following this
wild group of bonobos for
a long time for many months and of
course they don't usually meet other
communities and we can get into that why
is it that typically interactions are
within the community
uh and then suddenly the study group
you know they have this way of traveling
which seems very
very intentional
and you can tell it when you observe it
they suddenly kind of switch onto okay
we're going somewhere and they cross the
river which typically demarcates their
territory and i went like oh god where
are they going
these guys are going somewhere like very
intentionally
and they went into the territory of the
neighboring community
so i was like whoa
something's going to happen here because
it doesn't happen very often and in
chimpanzees when chimpanzees meet other
communities typically they try not to
because it's aggressive and
you can have neighboring basically males
that patrol the territory and they will
kill a male of the other community
and
sometimes not only kill but also maim
for instance they will
take out their genitals it's very very
yeah that's why
this bonobo observation i think is
poignant
because
i mean
there's this joke i cannot okay i'll ask
you um what's the most vulnerable part
of the mail and not to me well
i think well it's a leading question
it's a leading question yes
i would imagine having a bonobo poland
poke my genitals would make me feel very
vulnerable
yes right but that's the point really
and that i think that's the take home of
this story
it is an extremely vulnerable part of
the male anatomy and so and it's
actually used that as such in aggressive
interactions and so that you actually
use it in playful interactions
it's i think
playing with a line of trust
vulnerability and real
life risk
that's extremely interesting and gets at
the root
of what play is
and so these males were playing and they
were males from different communities
so
what kind of trust do you need to build
in order to have
this kind of interaction between males
that don't
usually live together
or are related yeah to be a very unusual
greeting among humans right so
correct take a trip to kansas city and
walk up to a stranger and
grab them by the balls
please do not do this
i don't recommend
yeah
outside home
yes
so we're going to come back to
bonobo land because we're going to talk
a lot about bonobos but
this uh
suffice to say genital play comes up a
lot
and you have matriarchs
holding on to males by the genitals
walking them around in circles you have
lots and lots of this type of play and
this is not a prescriptive
recommendation to anyone out there but
it is interesting so we're going to come
back to it i thought i would just rewind
for a second because we mentioned a lot
of things in your bio we mentioned
applied evolutionary ethologist for
instance let's start there what is
an evolutionary ethologist and what is
an applied evolutionary ethologist
ethology is the study of behavior so i
might as well just use behavioral
sciences
but
i use histology because it's my own
particular
field of training people might be
familiar with the work of conrad lorenz
no i'm not so oh okay so um western
mythology animal behavior comes
from
from a group of people that were in
europe studying animal behavior
and when they were studying animal
behavior they went well you know there
are
pressures and adaptations in other
animals that are interesting in
themselves but that they also help us
think about our own behavior
and and so for them it was very
important to observe behavior as
naturally occurring occurring in in
in habitats where animals live so of
course we can still observe behavior you
know in cages
and in zoos and inside homes
and that has its own value
but uh a seathologist we try to observe
behavior as well in in the wild because
when it's interacting with ecology i
think it tells us something very
important about you know the environment
in which animals have evolved and what
does this tell us about their behavior
today so that's
ethology and then the word applied
i use it in the sense that i was trained
and worked as a mythologist but almost
without
wanting or thinking about it i can't
help but think about the world and the
problems that we have today
so whenever you think about say
cooperation competition
play
aggression
obviously your mind goes okay what does
this tell us about war and creativity
and innovation and so on so applied is
really trying to cross that bridge
between science and society
great answer very helpful thank you all
right so now would lorenz i'm thinking i
don't know this particular name
but would
would bf skinner have been a
an overlap in terms of timing or would
skinner have come much later
on in terms of looking at i guess
classical and operant conditioning and
things like that so that's a great
question i think not only in timing but
also in terms of approach
so lorenz
let me tell you an anecdote about
laurence and we'll go to skinner what
was the full name of lorenz
conrad with kate conrad lorenz conrad
lorenz great name
yeah
he was observing birds
and
he's most famous for having brought up
geese
so he had these incubators with geese
eggs
and he discovered imprinting namely that
when the eggs hatched the first thing
that the chicks look at if it was him
rather than
the
the female
the the chicks would imprint on him so
he effectively i mean this is
this is not quite what ethologists would
do today right but we're talking about
the origin story
and so
he started walking basically the chicks
would follow him
and he learned the vocalization so he
learned to communicate with them and go
like
and then they would follow him and he
became like the mother geese
i love that because of course again
don't do this at home and we wouldn't
want to do it today as scientists but i
think there's something about
really putting literally yourself in the
feet
and the wings and the mind of another
animal as much as you can
as the other animal rather than as a
human that
help you
become a better scientist
and so i think lorenz had that genius
and he tried to look at the animals in
themselves
right and then i guess skinner in
contrast was like we can't understand
the inner life of animals so we're just
going to look at observable behavior
please correct me if i'm getting any of
this wrong but like stick them in a box
and then you know shock them and do
various things and we're just going to
like clinically take notes on it so very
different
yes very different very different
approach based on very different
assumptions right yes very different
assumptions and actually completely
understandable because of course skinner
was trying to do science and he was
trying to isolate variables
and to do controlled experiments which
is you know
an essential part of science so it's not
that i think this
i mean and today i mean and of course
conrad also economics did things that
today wouldn't be considered proper
science either i think these guys were
experimenting in different ways and
today we have a conciliance and
integration
of the experimental side of of behavior
and and the naturalistic observations
that is kind of exciting i think yeah
totally and i want to give you credit
for a great word conciliance i just want
to define this for people that is a
[ __ ] great word
noun agreement between the approaches to
a topic of different academic subjects
especially science and the humanities
there's also a book by eo wilson called
consilience that people might check out
it's it's a bit dense but consilience is
a great word so thank you for that thank
you for spotting that i love that yeah
absolutely and i think the contrast of
conrad and
bf skinner is interesting on a whole
bunch of levels and it's something that
has fascinated me for a long time for
instance i watched
documentary i believe the name is nim or
project nim and it spoke to
i want to say
an ex let's just say a field experiment
also with laboratory experiments that
was conducted in the perhaps the 60s or
early 70s
and the premise was attempting to raise
a baby chimpanzee as a human
and
[Music]
spoiler alert it ended up being quite a
train wreck but what they observed and
when i say they i should be very
specific the let's just call it field
adoptive parents of this chimpanzee is
that the chimpanzee
would exhibit all of these incredible
behaviors outside of the lab but as soon
as you brought this particular champ
into the lab they just refused to
cooperate or at the very least didn't
exhibit these behaviors so
when
i'm having conversations with any number
of folks and i i love science i'm very
involved with with funding science and
they say well do they have
uh randomized controlled studies related
to x in a laboratory my my answer
sometimes is you can't really do it or
it's very very hard
particularly with in this case maybe an
obvious example of of animal behaviors
so let's
let's jump from there
back in time further
to
darwin and humboldt now i expect a lot
of people listening will recognize
darwin but they may not recognize
humboldt so
if we really rewind the clock you just
give us
some of the history the early history of
evolutionary thinking
because this is also something i don't
know a lot about but it just came up
last week in conversation with
someone named noah feltman who's been on
the podcast very smart guy and he raised
a couple anecdotes that i had never
heard so
take it away
all right
evolutionary thinking let's not go to
the origins origins because evolutionary
thinking we can actually
date it to
greek times and uh and how the greeks
would understand say fossils that were
found and whether they would interpret
them as you know
extraordinary animals or being part of
mythologies but
so
what i'm going to say is like modern
it's about modern evolutionary thinking
so
origins of evolutionary thinking if you
think about evolution you will picture
an old darwin old charles darwin with a
long beard correct so like the lone
genius that had this great idea which by
the way
the philosopher daniel dennett says the
best idea i ever thought was evolution
and so let's define what is this like
such amazing idea
the simple idea that all life is related
so evolution really is about how all
life is related and how all life evolves
everything has an origin
and like king lear said nothing comes
from nothing so darwin himself was the
grandson of and this extraordinary man
who was called erasmus darwin
erasmus darwin
was a polymorph he was a doctor he was
creative he was a poet
he is one of the biggest influences on
the romantic poets on byron
and many others
so
darwin inherited first of all these
you know
strange influences
and erasmus darwin used to hold these
meetings uh in his home um they were
called the lunar society when they were
trying to find out basically about
life and creativity and you know as
polymaths do
[Laughter]
the poly mouth happy hour
let's get to the bottom of all knowledge
well it actually is a big point the
lunar society was called like that
because
they would
meet once a month in full moon and of
course drinking and food sharing was
involved and they had to
ride back home and so a full moon would
actually be a very practical thing
[Laughter]
good call good call yeah nothing
mystical about it it's just like we're
gonna be drunk off our asses we need to
be able to see the sidewalk right oh
yeah reality empiricism
and so
erasmus darwin had in his
chariot an emblem called
in latin life comes from the sea
the point what i'm trying to make here
is that
darwin himself
had ancestors both intellectual
ancestors but also family ancestors that
were thinking about evolution
often you know ideas are in the
environment so that's the family side of
darwin
equally or if not more important i think
for darwin was the influence of
alexander von humboldt
von humboldt was is a prussian
aristocrat who was born the same year
than
napoleon i think
1769.
and he died by the way on 1859 which is
the date that darwin published the
origin of the species so there's like an
interesting evolutionary contingency
there and von humboldt he was an
explorer a genius uh another polymath
scholar and i think above all
which is the point that i want to link
between
darwin and humboldt and the origins of
how we think about nature and how we
think about evolution
they were neither of them were
white coat
lab
scientists
or or just scholars that live within
four walls they were both explorers and
they were both adventurous and they were
both naturalists and this is super
important because i think
it's a tradition of thinking that
basically has given us the the most
important ideas that we have today on
evolution and nature and let me
synthesize those ideas
humboldt
leaves
europe
and embarks in this extraordinary trip
to south america and of course i'm not
biased but they were both interested but
you're back
of course
i'm not biased but let me tell you
exactly
where in south america
all over the place but not quite a
humble
goes to venezuela colombia and ecuador
and he climbs chimborazo and basically
he does an anandayan route
he never got to chile unfortunately
but darwin spent around three years in
chile the voyage of the beagle that we
can
talk about separately
but the five-year voyage of the beagle
three years ish were in chile which i
think is super important
basically he spent a long a lot more
time there than in galapagos i need to
say that
quick question why did von humboldt
choose to go where
that expedition ended up going
first the new world in a nutshell
the
the excitement of the new world he also
he needed to get out first of all he
needed to get out of europe because his
mother had
very high hopes for him as a civil
servant
so
so when his father died he
he had an inheritance and he decided to
spend it funding his own adventure mom
must have loved that
right because she was like socially
i don't say snow but ish oh she was high
society right yeah exactly yeah exactly
old world
like brahman yeah yeah no exactly so
it's like you
you're gonna give me grandchildren that
have you know a certain position right
yeah and he was like oh
i'm going to venezuela mom
see you when i see you exactly
i have my own fans
but i mean it's a longer story and oh i
okay can i if you want to read about
this i would really recommend the most
fantastic book i've read in the last few
years by andrea wolfe
it's called
the invention of nature
and there are several books about von
humboldt but in andrea wolf's research
she brings together the adventure the
naturalist and also
the influences so
what i think to me is amazing as a
scientist is that we all know about
darwin and we can see his image
immediately you go like oh yeah old guy
with beard right
but
who's who is humbled and why we don't
actually know more about him humbled was
the direct
you know intellectual father of darwin
darwin was reading humble's diaries of
his explorations in south america and
when darwin gets invited to go on the
beagle he was actually thinking of
humboldt and in patagonia when he's
actually is called he's a very bad
sailor he hates being on board which is
another topic this is darwin this is
darwin he would puke and you know get
seasick and
which i think it was good because then
it meant that he had to go in london
that's a different topic but the point
is that he's he's writing he's writing
his voyage of the beagle diaries and
citing her humbled saying thank you if
it weren't for you i would have not
taken this voyage
which is amazing how this kind of
lineages and
of influence so you have one hand
humboldt that invents inverted commas
the modern concept of nature because you
really invent the concept of ecology how
things are interrelated so the field of
complex systems the field of ecosystems
as complex systems i really think takes
a lot of
from humboldt because
and this is important see the british
tradition is about taxonomy and
organization in boxes lineals
but whether it was because he was german
and also humbled as a young man had
spent time in jenna
with guerte
and with the creatives and poets of the
of the early romantics
and so i think that experience really
opened his mind
as uh
you know
to the future scientists that he would
become
you're smiling wow just casually hanging
out with goethe man
what an era
i know
i know
it's just going out to coffee with gouta
oh my god
yeah as one does i wanted to read
a letter from letters of note which i
recommend to everyone this they have
instagram they have a website they have
books letters of note which are copies
of old letters
generally older letters from people of
note to other people and there's a
there's an excerpt of one letter from
charles darwin to charles lyell i
believe it is l-y-e-l-l from october 1st
1861
and it reads but i am poorly today and
very stupid and hate everybody and
everything so he didn't always have good
days
yes
i love that letter so much
yes this is incredible
let me really make a large leap here to
a question that might seem strange but
a lot has happened a lot has been
observed a lot has been studied a lot
has been found since
humbolt and darwin's day
as it stands right now what are some of
the most interesting
theories
or let's just call them theories or
findings related to
evolutionary biology
and i'd love to know if there are any
newer let's just say in the last
10 20 years
theories related to evolution that that
people might find interesting or
surprising and i'm going to keep talking
for a second just to also buy time
and part of the reason i'm asking this
is as someone who really does not has
not studied evolutionary biology i would
like to think i have a basic
understanding but that's probably hubris
i've had two different dinners recently
in the last
few months
with two incredibly smart people who
granted
come from religious families so i want
to
grant that
but
both of them have also extremely strong
mathematics backgrounds
and
you know in effect after a couple
glasses of wine
the
they raised a couple of names and they
said well we're not sure
if
it seems probabilistically that sort of
the the original
let's just call it
description of evolutionary thinking
per the era of say darwin and so on
can't really account for the for all
that we've observed to date and i don't
know if that's nonsense i don't know if
there could be anything to it
but i would love to hear any and all
thoughts it doesn't have to relate to
that specifically but certainly it
planted a seed and they were like well
go check out this person who's a
credible scientist who agrees with me
but
i haven't i haven't actually done that
homework so
any thoughts
of course
i don't know what these mathematicians
specifically are referring to so i would
need to you know assess it but
i would mention one thing
i think the most exciting
revolutionary
aspect
of the last
save well let's call it 50 years
is a
sort of integration
between darwin
and complexity
so you know santa fe institute meets
darwin right meets humboldt and let me
explain why
because darwinis and naturalists
described the mechanisms
by which new species arise namely
natural selection he also described
sexual selection
and then you might say well what's the
difference
i remember a teacher saying look at
nature look at any structure that seems
useless
and then typically that will be a result
of sexual selection
peacock feather versus a wings anyway so
darwin described both sexual selection
natural selection
could you actually just take a second to
expand on that so sexual selection is
something that doesn't have a utility
per se but it could be
a i think you said a feather like a
particular
i guess a mating dance would be too
obvious it's no but it is so it's
selected
say
team is funny and tim gets to reproduce
because he's funny so it's right
you know
one can hope a boy can dream yeah
sorry that wasn't awful
that was perfect that was perfect
the jury's still out tbd yeah
all right
we are lonely species
and
and males have some advantages in that
respect
so yeah although technology also brings
other possibilities anyway
but it's actually now that i think about
it it's not such a bad example because
you would say
what advantages would being funny
actually bring you know you're spending
cognitive energy in something you're
being silly you're spending time and
maybe you're distracted maybe if you're
too distracted the predator will get you
but if
females like it
well that trait will get selected so
and that works for
feathers you know
cleverness there are many traits that
you can go with this looks like
expensive and annoying and and inorderly
colorful but there are traits that
evolve and get selected again and again
because mates choose them
so i pulled you off topic
in part just to explore the sexual
selection piece but you're saying all
right so darwin covered natural
selection
right like too slow you get eaten by
saber tooth tiger kind of thing
sexual selection which would be say the
colors of the feathers not for flight
purposes but for say mating purposes
humor you gave another example
but
you were you're going to explain how
darwin
plus complexity is something else now in
this case i don't actually know what
complexity refers to so
i would love to love to hear more
i think i don't want to get in trouble
with the mathematicians but i think uh
uh
a broad way of describing complexity is
how things interact with other things so
is in a way the
the study of structure
and that's why complexity combined with
evolutionary theory is important because
they are not only genetic in genetic
information being passed
but
organisms exist within structures namely
societies but also ecosystems
and these structures impose dynamics of
their own
in turn that influence the organisms let
me give you a specific example on how
these two domains combine
the two domains being complexity
and evolutionary thinking
which is going back to your question of
what do i think is most interesting as a
development today it's niche
construction
the concept of niche construction are
you familiar with this
i know those two words separately but
i'm not sure what they mean in this
country that's great fantastic fantastic
so
niche construction is basically to
construct the niche okay what does that
mean
so far i got you so far yes exactly
great so darwin described how worms
earthworms
are are not only adapted to their
environment but also in the process of
living
they
they modify the environment they're in
so a worm travels creates burrows it
defecates in doing so changes the
organisms that are available changes the
frequency of these organisms also
changes
the ph of the soil and so on namely the
activity of an organism modifies the
environment in which the organism is in
and i mentioned the example of
of earthworms because
it's a very basic simple example this is
most obvious when we think about humans
every organism on earth is a niche
constructor i
organisms are not passive things that
just adapt to their environment which i
think it was the old way of seeing
things like an organism is
a thing that basically has to respond
and adapt
and the revolution i think is that in
niche construction you go organisms are
also agents of their own change because
by the process of living they modify
themselves each other and their
environments so if you think about that
other animals say humans we not only
modify our environments physically but
also we are cultural niche constructors
which means that we live in worlds that
are also cultural by creating these
worlds then you have to adapt to them if
you have to adapt to them that changes
the feedback loop on your own existence
so that's why
in traits that would ten thousand years
ago would have not been very useful for
survival now they might be very useful
and the other way around
so that's why i think
and we can that's a longer conversation
but the notion of cultural niche
construction
i think it's exciting it combines
elements
of
mathematical complexity theory although
i don't want to get in trouble with the
mathematicians i'm very scared of them
[Laughter]
go talk to the santa fe institute people
about this
yeah no problem yeah and what i'll also
do do any names come to mind uh
researchers scientists mathematicians or
otherwise who
comment or and have investigated and
studied the intersection of say
darwinian thought with complexity do any
names come to mind or we can certainly
do some homework
the original book on this was published
by john odlin smee and kevin leyland
mathematician
two mathematicians and
naturalists broadly understood
and today i would point out to david
krakauer who is the president of the
santa fe institute and i think he
himself in his
thinking and
just the work he does kind of embodies
this perfect also they have a lot of
great applied work santa fe institute
for instance i would suggest reading
what they published in relation to
understanding the pandemic
from this point of view i i think this
approach is incredibly enlightening
all right we'll link to all of those in
the show notes so people will be able to
find everything that we just mentioned
or i'm using the royal we everything
that you just mentioned and you know
what you said about niche constructors
niche constructors
modifying their environment which in
turn creates this feedback loop reminds
me of the the winston churchill quote we
shape our tools and then the tools shape
us
and it and it applies all the way from
the earthworm to for instance large
herbivores in africa if you look at
hippopotami
and the paths that they create which
affect water flow and and a million
other things
it's just
incredible how interconnected
all of it is and how many feedback loops
exist so you do need some mathematics
to begin to try to
evaluate how these
many hundreds and thousands and
millions of feedback loops might
interact in any way that we can
comprehend so i'll check out david
krakauer that's a great lead
how many bonobos
are there in the world at this point
roughly speaking
it's a very difficult to have an exact
number but
they would fill out a small stadium
maybe hopefully more than 10 000 and
probably less than 60 000
got it and just for comparison purposes
how many chimpanzees are there
is it a multiple of that is it roughly
the same for sure it's at least one
order of magnitude more
i'm thinking
no not two orders of magnitude
but if you sum the three subspecies
i want to say
around the million or less but actually
let me get back to you with the late
discount no because of yeah
bonobos and chimpanzees are contrasted
because they seem to have so many
differences of
not just styles personalities behavior
their societal structure right
and i do want to talk about
all these things
why is there such a discrepancy in the
number of bonobos versus chimpanzees is
it
due to the state of affairs in congo is
it because
they're
in
for whatever reason not
naturally
selected as well right and you know is
that could that be a plausible vote in
favor of aggression i don't know
uh how would you describe the the
discrepancy and i'm not fishing for a
yes answer to the latter i'm just saying
it's it's
i hadn't thought about this until i
prepared for this interview and i was
like why are there so few bonobos and i
didn't have a good answer to that
i think the word is contingency
evolutionary contingency
namely
probably the
evolutionary event that led to the
speciation
of of these two species speciation
meaning
what happens when you have an ancestral
population of no an ape that was the
grandfather of chimps and bonobos
something happens and later down the
river of time
you have two distinct populations one is
bonobos one is
chimpanzees
was prop this event was probably but
we're still discussing about it the
formation the geographical formation of
the river congo the river congo is an
enormous river that in order for you
guys to picture it think
don't think of a river think more of
like a moving lake
if anyone has visual images of the
amazon
or any any of this
the congo is only second in size to the
amazon is really the congo basin and the
amazonian basin are equivalent they're
both of them are the lungs of our planet
so you have this enormous river
and north of the river congo you have
the distribution of chimpanzees and
south of the river congo you have
bonobos which means
that
at the
time and both species adapt
and niche construct with and
their environment bonobo environment is
a lot more
wet and
tropical jungle
than chimpanzees having said this
there's a huge variation in chimpanzee
habit that chimpanzees are probable but
i mean i say this with so many caveats
because bonobos also have ability to
exist in somehow drier environments but
as a as a gross over generalization
chimps exist in in a more varied
array
of landscapes i they can be in like
tropical forests but also in
in drier environments which probably you
know it's a chicken and egg thing can
they be there because they're better at
adapting or is it because they were
north of the river that they actually
adapted that way
you know
what we know is what we find today and
so i think it's contingency
and you know sometimes they hunt
sometimes they don't in depending
whether in dry environments they hunt
more depending
uh this is chimpanzees yes yes sorry
chimp disease
both species are incredibly flexible
but chimpanzees have a wider
distribution and perhaps in terms of the
dietary adaptations they might be more
flexible
on the dietary side just because
i'm extending our conversation that we
had
many months ago
i and i'm just curious so i'm going to
follow my curiosity so apologies to
everyone who's expecting a really
well-constructed
60-point
sequential set of questions here but on
the dietary side do
bonobos
hunt has that been observed and uh maybe
you could speak to chimpanzees because i
mean my
very very minimal understanding of
chimpanzees is that you know not only do
they hunt but they also kind of sport
hunt in a way or do
like they go on raids of sorts could you
just maybe speak to both and
contrast and i would just love to know
because i've never asked anyone and
you're the person to ask if bonobos have
ever been observed to hunt
both species hunt um chimpanzees hunt
more than bonobos that's the summary
and now let's dig into this
um
so for for years the
archetype was that chimps were you know
mean aggressive hunters
and runoffs were like the nice vegan
you know love
loving orgy lovers exactly thank you
suddenly i became coy but i don't know
why
yeah what was that all about you just
got so shy
[Laughter]
but yes thank you
and
i think that's what's so cool about
studying animals and about science that
things are always more complex and have
more
variance and nuance and as you
understand more the animals particularly
when you're dealing with large brain
intelligent animals like the of course
they're plastic of course they change of
course not all the populations do the
same stuff of course there's a huge
variation according to which
environments they're in so then you can
start making predictions and saying well
if they're in wetter environments if
they're in rich environment
how does this drive behaviors like
hunting and aggression and so on but
that's the domain of socioecology right
which is the study of how social
behavior changes according to
environmental pressures so having said
that i mentioned that because i think
it's important to understand that we are
also animals subjected to the same
pressure i guess what our environment
changes we change so for chimps and
burnovers it's the same we can even even
speak of say western chimpanzees have
been said of having a more bonobo
strategy in the sense of you know
females are
are you know have stronger bonds and
they can be nicer and hunt less than
eastern chimpanzees
that hunt more and there's you know more
events of aggression and geographically
could you just place us where where
would
the
range of the western chimpanzees be in
the versus the eastern and i know
there's probably not a super clear
demarcation down the middle but
geographically where are we placing
those groups
the eastern chimpanzee would be the
chimpanzee that
most people know because of djangoodle
studies so your gombe timp
right is your eastern chimp and i think
that's thank you for asking that
question because
of course for jane when she
started studying these gyms and the
things she observed
including the four-year war jane goodall
after a while she thought that
chimpanzees to begin with they were like
a nicer version of us
so i think this is inserted in a broader
context of of course we are looking at
ourselves by looking at these animals
and when you know she makes this amazing
discovery when she observes them using
tools and there's a famous anecdote she
writes to louise licki who had the idea
of her going there and saying look i
know that the definition of human is
that we use we're the only animal that
uses technology but i've observed these
animals namely chimpanzees using and
creating technology so we have a problem
basically we either
how we can handle the pr on this one dr
leakey
we have a problem dr leaky
either we widen the definition of you
know who can who is allowed to use
technology or we change the the the
meaning of being human right so that's a
very famous like i that's i hope that's
in letters of note by the way i don't
know if it is but it should be
that telegram it might be it might be i
mean they've gathered some incredible
letters yeah and people also i mean
can
hear quite a bit about some of these
earlier experiences that jane goodall
had
in my conversation with her so we
explore that quite a bit and they can
also find documentaries like jane
online which will give you quite a view
into
this four-year war as you mentioned i
mean really
i mean just as uh different tools
obviously different weaponry but just as
horrifying as human war i mean uh
i mean ongoing protracted war
which is not is not
isolated chimps right i mean we look at
certain
ant populations i mean as as if my
memory serves me correctly i mean there
are there's like decade plus long
wars going on i want to say somewhere in
the american southwest or near mexico
and then we get to the west where where
is
you can you can comment on any of that
they'd like
at some point we'd love to know where
the western chimps are
look at africa central africa note where
the congo river is which is on kind of
on the upper third bid of drc i'm
talking very broadly here and then look
west
and so a guinea
and cote d'ivoire
and all that area that is north of the
river on the west yeah i'm going into
google maps and looking at this right
now
you know you know what's interesting it
says gombe i'm looking at gombe oh yeah
i guess i got pulled into the wrong base
in tanzania yeah right but there's also
a gombe in nigeria so people should be
aware if they pull it up on a map gombe
is in tanzania in the in the context in
which we're using it
yeah so if you again look at the map of
africa and if you look at the heart of
it literally the heart of it
yeah that is zaire
drc democratic republic of congo yep to
the right
to the right of that you will find
gombe tanzania
and eastern africa
so that boundary and lake tanganyika is
in that boundary so when you actually
when you climb the hills of gumbay which
are steep and it's hardcore and one
reason to study unobos is that the congo
basin is flat but anyway
when you climb gombe
yeah and they're like killer bees on the
tanzanian side
when you climb gombe and you look down
at
atangenika then you can see
congo got it so that that is kind of the
line that i'm trying to draw so i'm
looking at a map here if you met so drc
democratic republic congo is kind of
smack in the middle of africa and if you
imagine that country this is going to
sound kind of funny but as
the united states
drc congo is the united states there's
actually a little hook in the southeast
that kind of looks like florida
if you were to look at where new england
is right on that border
let's just say going into the ocean that
would be uganda and then below that say
around where like new york new jersey
would be if you have rwanda burundi and
then you have
tanzania covering pretty much everything
down to
florida and there is the
this gigantic
lake as you mentioned it which i'm not
going to be able to pronounce properly
that forms the border
basically between
between drc
and tanzania what was the name of this
lake again
tanganyika right that gives you a bit of
an image so the western chimps where
does that group begin and this is this
is going somewhere folks so don't don't
worry well i'm not getting like totally
where's waldo with geography forever but
do they start west of that lake
so lake tanganyika goes
north
south it's like a very long and actually
very deep lake
i think it might actually be one of the
deepest lakes in the world
only after baikal i'm not sure
but
west of that you have gorilla
populations
so the the western chimpanzees are north
that's why
tanganyika
again think of drc as this heart of
africa
and then the river the congo river is on
the upper bed
right as conrad the writer
the author of the heart of darkness
described it because he sailed there
that's the origin of heart of darkness
in fact he described as an a coiling
snake
so
think of
of the congo river is this coiled
enormous coil snake that kind of goes
it's at the head of drc and drc
for context
is the size of western europe
is an enormous enormous country so
western chimpanzees are north west
of that i see you see what i mean yeah i
do
so you were talking about your
conversation with jane and the four-year
war on aggression in chimpanzees
the person
to read and listen and follow
about that work kind of the
who is the modern jane goodall in the
sense of following chimpanzee behavior
and working on aggression which is of
course and the origins of war which for
all very obvious reasons is a very
topical
issue today is richard rangham he is a
british primatologist
who
has been at harvard directing the pan
lab for many years he has many books
he's an incredibly creative thinker how
do you spell richard's last name rangam
w r a n
g h a m
right okay
perfect his last book is called the
goodness paradox the goodness paradox
yes
namely
why is it that humans are you know
relatively good
if we should in inverted comas
given what we see in trump disease be a
little more aggressive
and so i think all things that richard
covers are about this topic are
incredibly useful and he has been
observing chimpanzees well he worked
with jane
and so i can't recommend him
more thoroughly
that was one
yes and then the second you mentioned
war in ants and so
and the recommendation there would be
and you had also mentioned eo wilson joe
wilson yes the author of conciliance he
naturalist
and naturalist and um very famous for
sociobiology in 1964 namely
combining social sciences and natural
sciences
and creating a bit of steer in the
process
but his favorite student he's alive
today the student because you died
a couple of months very recently very
recently yeah
i would
invite everyone to
to read the work of mark moffett mark
moffett is also an ant
biologist the favorite student of eu
wilson i'm mark an explorer another
another person in this tradition of
doing theoretical work thinking about
animal and human societies but combining
exploration science
and theoretical thinking
he published a book called swarm
it's basically about human societies and
he makes this wonderful point that in
many respects
the dynamics of ants inform us about our
sociality including war a lot more than
we can see in other animals so that's a
recommendation very cool
swarm great name
great book title
if you look at the
let's just say contrasting behaviors of
western chimps and eastern chimps and
then bonobos
do you think it's primarily a function
of
food scarcity versus abundance or
something like that
i think that definitely plays into it
but i also think
that you have the niche construction
element there namely
that cultural animals
have
dynamics
of their own
that are perhaps put in place in first
place because of ecological conditions
but once they get going
they have their own
weight like a culture yeah
and their own sort of durability also
even if the initial conditions are not
the current conditions correct so this
example is soft yeah oh i was just going
to say also that as you mentioned i mean
you have
genetics as we understand it with or i
mean we i'm giving myself a lot of
credit there but
genetics in terms of dna and the code
that gets passed down
as we understand it environmentally
largely unmodified dna meaning you have
these random mutations that sometimes
lead to better fitness and then natural
selection but
we don't have to go down this rabbit
hole because it's also a rat hole it
gets co-opted by a lot of new agey stuff
but epigenetics also
sort of these these more acute
effects on
progeny and their behavior and so on
so please continue saying that the niche
construction
but so by cultural weight could you give
an example of that or that type of
the impact of that
so
selection pressures that
work
on behavior of social animals so let me
give you an example so when you observe
bonobos
immediately females
are very
they stand out as being very as we would
call them empowered i and they seem
to make decisions and to kind of have
the upper hand in the sense not that
bonobo males are in any way and let me
make this super clear bonobo males are
magnificent strong amazing males this is
not an example of
right off they're not like spider males
who get eaten after procreation no
exactly they are beautiful magnificent
males this is not an example of like a
war of the sexes where you have okay
females warn the war of the sexes and
these guys are like puny little guys on
the outskirts of society no
i can show you pictures videos they're
magnificent
and i think also they have fun they're
playful they're strong
but going back to the example you asked
for
immediately this difference between kind
of
vulnerable females being empowered they
they don't get raped for instance so
female choice is well female choice
exists throughout nature but rape can
happen in some societies and some
species
in in bonobos we have not observed rape
the males make like an invitation to
mate which is kind of a fun
head bob
it's like tango
right
sorry inside joke guys this is this is
how males invite women to dance from
like across the room anyway no but this
is correct
same same
no i failed as a rheumatologist and a
south american
so the males do this head bobbing thing
yes as the invitation
as the invitation that the point i want
to make is that you can ask
why
why is this happening in in bonobos say
as opposed to other
to other species and the thinking is
that the environment the wealth in the
environment
it played a very important role
in the development of bonobos because
let me backtrack and backtrack a little
bit into like socio socioecology 101
think what are your main problems if
you're a mammal if you're a female
mammal typically female mammals are
constrained by resources because being a
female mammal is expensive calorically
you have to travel if you're lactating
if you're carrying babies
there's a lot of investment that female
mammals
have to do with procreation and carrying
babies for sometimes a very long time
because mammals have large brains which
are in turn expensive to maintain
and babies can be useless and they're
born before they're ready to go right
in order to pass through the birth canal
or through the
uh to be born properly they're they're
born kind of helpless
that is most extreme in the case of
humans and humans yeah in humans yes but
i'm probably gonna speak no i'm sorry i
was i was thinking mostly of of kind of
higher primates and humans to be clear
like when a giraffe drops out it's got
to be ready to run or it's lion food so
yeah that's a great point actually
just think observe giraffes or any
large herbivore
the relative
period of uselessness
in an infant between these kind of
animals
versus us or gorillas chimps bonobos i
herbivores
whether it's a giraffe or a horse or a
or deer they get up and they start
walking they're still protected by the
mother and of course fed by the mother
but our babies are useless for a very
long time
the point being that it's expensive to
be a female mammal exactly thank you
it's expensive to be a female mammal so
female mammals are typically constrained
by resources and and so if you have an
environment where there aren't enough
resources
female mammals the most basic thing is
that they have to be on their own
because there isn't enough food for
everyone to gather
right so you know not enough
supermarkets can only fit say one female
and her two babies you're stuck on your
own if there is enough food
ah now you can go to a party i you can
hang out with other females right and
this is really important because i think
what like the social revolution for
bonobos was that female mammals were
able to hang out together
in order to form a bond you need a very
basic thing to happen
if you are a
primate that doesn't bond online
you need to be in the same physical
space
right and and because mammals bond
through physical interaction and so if
an environment allows
for females to be in the same place you
can afford that possibility not that it
will always happen
but we think that in bonobos the fact
that they were in a relatively wealthy
environment wealthy meaning a forest a
tropical forest with a lot of fruit and
fruit has you know high in calories
then you can be in the same place
so probably the and this is where you
get into the multiple feedback loops
females in the same place females
hanging out with each other social
proximity social proximity bonding
bonding alliances alliances we advance
our own interest what is our interest
female mammals have two problems well
there are many problems but one of them
is
right being energetically expensive and
the second one
is infanticide
so infanticide exists it's relatively
widespread uh
and so if you think i'm i'm like i'm
gonna sound like a horrible person
without a heart
but if you think of like your genetic
your genetic investment take taking away
love
or a terrible thing to say obviously
for a female mammal your your child
being killed is an awful thing
and so purely because of the time and
energy invested in creating and
maintaining this infant so what i'm
trying to get at is that the adaptations
for female mammals that have to do with
avoiding infanticide are important
so in that sense
choosing males that are nice males and
not choosing males that will probably be
infanticidal
it's an important thing
oh interesting okay so i have questions
can maya jump in with a question about
this yeah so when i hear this is
probably not a sentence i use very often
but when i hear infanticide what i think
about is
uh cases with say
lions bears it's very very common in the
natural world where a
let's just call it a challenger male
will come to a pride
kill a resident male
and
that that that male lion will want the
female lines to go into estrus
so
if they are lactating that won't happen
therefore he will kill
the cubs and this happens amongst bears
is my understanding
but you're saying in this case there's
also infanticide where the actual
biological father will kill
the infants
not typically
no no no not typically i i meant i'm
sorry i should have been
specific about that what i wanted to say
is that infanticide as you're pointing
out happens in nature
and avoiding infanticide the only thing
that i'm saying is that avoiding
infanticide it's important for females
it's important yeah totally so what i'm
trying to get at is that i think you
asked about
the contribution of a you know wealthy
environment that you know why are bruno
so nice right is that is it because they
have more fruit i think that plays into
it but i also think it's a cultural
niche construction but also
you have multiple levels of selection i
think what we see is that
females have been
selecting nice males and nice males get
rewarded for being nice
because females choose them so
what you see is that multiple feedback
loops
the
the way of summarizing this better i
think was done by the rapper baba
brinkman uh when
he's a great lyricist and he wrapped
the original species but so
so when when he was rapping about how
sexual selection works and these
processes are basically female choice
um and he was showing
gangsters and you know kind of a rap
culture being all aggressive and she
said girls you are selecting traits in
males so in order to create a better
world don't sleep with mean people
i think that's
yeah good advice good advice i i think i
mean i'm obviously saying it as a joke
but what i'm trying to illustrate here
is that
female sexual choice is important and in
bonobos because of what was
possible for them to happen given that
they were able to form coalitions uh
perhaps we see it more clearly that's
all let me ask a couple of kind of
housekeeping questions that may go
nowhere so i apologize to everyone if
this goes nowhere
but if you look at say bonobo versus
chimpanzee populations
what does
is there a different gender split so if
you look at a given cohort i don't even
know how you would define that it's
probably not a single troop it's
probably a little wider than that but
if you look at bonobos is it like 50 50
male female and chimps roughly the same
is it 60 40 is it 80 20 and second
question is about body size discrepancy
between males and females in bonobos
is the discrepancy the same as in chimps
and i'm trying to think of other factors
aside from food scarcity or abundance
that might contribute to different
social dynamics
so both species have the same sex ratio
around 50 50.
and in terms of
it tim is asking about dimorphism so
sexual dimorphism is if you look at
males and females if roughly the body
size and other traits are kind of
similar or whether you see big
differences so yeah one example of like
huge dimorphism would be
guerrillas like the males think of a
male silverback big enormous guy and
females much smaller or say
a stag a deer red deer
as a rule of thumb again grossly over
generalizing dimorphism indicates
lack of monogamy
so i mean again
maybe we shouldn't get into this because
there are many nuances here but uh
in chimpanzees and bonobos the
male
female size females are a little bit
smaller
in both species and dimorphism might be
a little bit
more in chimpanzees namely
you don't see this huge body size
difference but there is a body size
difference in humans is
it's evident as well in the sense of
like most males if you think of averages
are are you know
taller heavier
uh stronger than females and obviously
they're exceptions but we're talking
statistically if we come back to what
you said related die for die
i've never said that word before
dimorphism yes if we come back to what
you said about dimorphism that that is
reflective or indicative of a
lack of monogamy is that right
typically
could you elaborate on that
let's think about animals that have most
dimorphism again
let's pick the stag
deer or
gorillas
typically that indicates a harem social
structure in the sense of
one male and several females
and
that will and of course it's not as
simple
as that with time we have learned that
gorilla's social systems are a lot more
flexible than we thought
i mean that's another rule of thumb it's
always more complicated
than anything i think oscar wilde has a
great quote about that the truth isn't
very simple no what's that quote i'll
look it up yeah yeah
it's a rule of thumb
bonobos and chimpanzees are similar i
think in much more ways than we think
they're different
in the past i think because we were
coming out
of or we still are in a kind of thinking
of
evil and
and goodness so chimpanzees were like
the bad guys and bonobos were the good
guys and
chimpanzees are technological
machiavelli politicians
and
you know
male rapists and then bonobos are the
feminists like peace loving
and again
life is a lot more complicated
and so i would just really like to
stress
that
we should try to get out of of this kind
of
sharp contrast
both species have
undergone their own paths
i don't think it's correct to say good
guys and bad guys or there are no angels
but nobody's are no angels there's
conflict at every level of organization
and nature
and also i think we should be careful
about the naturalistic fallacy
naturalistic fallacy meaning oh if this
happens in nature it means that this is
okay for for us to to do the same
in human societies or this ought to be
the way
sorry i said a lot there but i don't
learn very much when i'm talking so i
prefer you to talk
and the oscar wilde quote
although you know half the quotes on the
internet are attributed to
oscar wilde but i believe
that the quote is the truth is rarely
pure and never simple
that's it thank you yeah that's the one
yeah
for people who don't have
the
context when you talk about
heart of darkness
congo could you describe
the land in which these bonobos live
from a from a human perspective right
what what what does the congo
look like what are some
what are some basics that we should know
about the congo just so people have an
appreciation for
what it means to
walk more than 3 000 kilometers on foot
in the jungles of the congo
so congo is
historically
you will hear about the two congos congo
brazil and congo
when we're talking about congo we mean
congo kinshasa meaning drc democratic
republic of congo what was known before
zaire so again picture africa literally
picture the heart of it this
enormous big central middle
and and that is congo
drc
congo is the size of western europe as
we were talking before it's
it has a given that it's so large there
are many
biomes but i went to the tropical
jungles in the
literally in the heart of congo namely
about 100 miles south of the river
just in the line of the equator so my
gps would mark zero zero zero zero
about 600
kilometers 400 miles from the nearest
town
this means that first of all you have
logistics that are complicated that are
the logistics
of any tropical rainforests
there are dangers that are inherent in
tropical rainforests such as trees
falling
in fact that's one of the most dangerous
things if you follow following a group
of
large-bodied animals that are arboreal
and you are a biped and these guys are
traveling on the trees
and this is a primary forest namely
their old and dying and dead trees many
times entire
pieces of you know
whether or not sometimes a tree but a
huge branch sometimes the size of a
table would fall you know a few inches
from you and so that has caused injury
permanent injury and actually a death in
the group of people that
live in the
in the study site
there are other obvious dangers
like snakes
they were green mambas black mamas congo
vipers
we couldn't have
anti-venom because for antivenom you
need
electricity in order to have a fridge
and to store it refrigeration
refrigeration so we didn't have
electricity
or any form of
you know public sanitation
for that matter so i think for me i was
always thinking about the the lack of
you you really shouldn't get bitten by a
snake that that's the bottom line
don't get bitten by a snake
yeah
good advice you get advice yeah 101.
the most obvious
danger i think with congo
for a woman would be
physical violence from people
congo is the rape capital of the world
but
this pertains to the
chronic
conflict that
congo has
but i was quite far
from that conflict that conflict happens
mostly in the east
of course it could erupt any time and it
was a concern
but uh
but i think i was more in the kind of
dangers of the forest i would say
then there's disease a tropical disease
yeah you you think you can control many
things but i took this book
called
the oxford handbook of tropical medicine
i did not read it beforehand and i think
if i would have read it beforehand it
maybe it would have been there's a small
degree of ignorance that sometimes is
helpful no i'm not advocating actually
i should take that back because of
course
i'm all about knowing and knowledge
but
play with the snakes play with play with
no no don't play with the snakes kidding
i'm kidding don't play business
no uh the the the chapter in this book
about infectious disease in in tropical
areas in central africa is quite scary
and
yeah that's the only thing i'm going to
say about that yeah so you have i mean
certainly in the urbanized or less
remote parts of congo you have warfare
you have
violence you have rape as you mentioned
disease
also right i mean
sort of urban disease
birthplace of ebola and hiv is that
correct correct yes yeah so you have a
lot going on you talked about the
dangers
some of the remote dangers you're
navigating all of this in the course of
doing field work
just to shift gears for a second because
you mentioned the death by
by tree
why is it that the japanese i think
university of kyoto has such
a dominant
role it would seem in bonobo research
how did that happen great question thank
you
we were talking about western mythology
and conduct lawrence so animal behavior
studies in the west
come from that line of animal behavior
in europe which
whose origin is in biology okay
the japanese have a different tradition
in ethology
that for them comes
broadly speaking from the social
sciences
and let me explain i think this is
really interesting
because you see
two
cultures coming at the same broadly
speaking
area of study with different approaches
the book for more this is by franz de
val
the dutch mythologist is called
the ape and the sushi master
it's a great title in which he
asks this question like why
where and are the japanese so interested
in animal behavior
the japanese came to animal behavior
with the kind of questions we're asking
today earlier than the west
probably for two reasons
one of them is a contingency an
evolutionary contingency namely habitat
in japan
there are primates you have japanese
monkeys so people i would invite
your audience to google japanese monkey
hot tub and what you will see right i
don't know the proper name but the snow
monkeys yes the incredible in the in the
hot springs
yeah japanese macaque
also known as a snow monkey yeah and so
the reason i'm mentioning that is
because i i like you to imagine what it
means for culture to live in a place
where you have these animals nearby and
so that means that
for the japanese primates monkeys were
part of the mythology and of their
stories
so think of the mythologies and the
stories that we have in the west and are
intelligent animals they're mostly say
ravens or foxes
think of like german fairy tales who's
clever oh it's the raven and why for
obvious reasons because those were the
animals that were available in our
environment so
we think and interacted with them we
didn't have monkeys
for for the west to look at monkeys we
had to go to africa to asia
so that's that's the first reason that i
think it's evolutionary contingency
namely the japanese
as a culture co-evolved with primates in
the presence and they were part of the
mythology and the story
i think also their religion
shinto so you know more about shinto
than i do but basically
interrelationships
i think that predisposed cognitively the
japanese to be much more prepared to
think about continuities and
discontinuities between
humans and other primates
so the combination of these two factors
made that
in the 1940s already you had a tradition
of japanese primatology
that was looking at first there was this
guy who was looking at
horse behavior and then he started
looking
at other
primates behavior and very famously he
discovered
the innovation of potato washing and so
this female that you know they were
eating potatoes
that had sand and you know everyone you
cannot go that's kind of annoying but
still food and she learned to wash them
in in the water and her friends and
family learned from her so it became a
very well-known example of innovation
and also who innovates and how
innovations spread through social
networks and anyway so that that
tradition yeah where was that potato
washing
do you recall
yes in an island
oh gosh i just forgot the name of the
island the
emo the name of the female is emo and
i'll get back to you with the name
that's funny because it means potato
so there's a joke in japanese
this is not going to mean anything to
anybody but
is a is a joking way it kind of sounds
like what time is it now
but it means don't touch the potato i've
just picked but emol
is a way of saying potato
or i think you can also use it to mean
like country bumpkin in japanese but
that's funny oh that's great
yeah so emo monkey
yeah potato
washing i'm just pulling it up really
quickly so i want to ask you
a question about this all right sweet
potato washing revisited 50th
anniversary of primates article so this
is
something i'm looking at on
springer.com
talks about koshima monkeys so i'm
guessing it's on koshima koshima island
yes yeah so koshima
almost certainly means little island
coal is
like kochigari for those judo people out
there koshima and then shima is like you
know hiroshima wide island
koshima so koshima now i had heard i
would love to the reason i'm asking
specifically
is
i wanted to ask you is it true and it
may not be at all but
let me back up and say
it seems to be
it seems to be true that there's this
phenomenon of of people in humans in
disparate geographical locations
having similar or identical scientific
breakthroughs around the same time
which
is
uh bizarre and raises a lot of questions
could just all be coincidence but it
seems to happen on a reasonably regular
basis when you read these biographies of
scientists it's like it's it's like you
know nothing happens for 200 years and
then it's like neck and neck down to the
weak right and
i believe something like that also
happened with darwin where he thought
he'd been beaten yeah darwin and wallace
yeah so wallace kind of beat him to the
punch and he wrote a letter to his
friend complaining like the other letter
and then his friend was like charles you
got to get your ass on this
get after it and then he pushed forward
and then no one remembers wallace right
so it's like nothing nothing nothing and
then flash boil all of a sudden and
i remember someone telling me that this
was also true for the sweet potato
washing in the sense that
i guess in this case emul
learns to wash these potatoes and then
around the same time
monkeys of the same species on other
nearby islands began
washing sweet potatoes do you know if
this is even as a story
something that exists putting aside
maybe they travel from island to island
i mean they must have gotten there
somehow to begin with so
i suppose they do but do you have you
heard this this story at all i've heard
the
on the wackier
side of that there are some explanations
like morphic resonance you probably yeah
morphogenic fields and all that stuff
you know i don't want to drag you into
the mud here but what are your thoughts
on any of this i think if i may remain
empirical about it i i think also
thinking as an ecologist i think it's
first of all
it's attention bias namely there's an
effect of right yeah i mean also
given i'm trained as someone who looks
at nature and i'm astounded at like our
own blindness of like how many times can
i pass through a place without saying
something until i go oh what about this
and then i see it everywhere so yeah
so that that is one thing it's like
buying a new car and then you see that
car everywhere it's like no no it's not
like everyone bought it the same day you
just didn't notice it before yeah
amazing so there's that effect but
that's not all i think there's also an
ecosystem effect
namely
that inventions
don't
quite i mean this view of like the lone
person whether it's a japanese macaque
female or darwin
alone like old man in his studio
we
think in ecosystems in environments
through interaction with the world so we
are picking up stuff that it's already
it's fruit that is in our forest so to
say so that other people start picking
it it's not
incredibly surprising
is there anyone you are aware of who is
a credible scientist
who would even entertain the notion of
morphic resonance or is interested in
alternative or complementary
theories for how some of these things
manifest or is that just universally
thought to be [ __ ]
i know rupert children personally and i
really like him okay
and i think the work his son marilyn you
probably know he's doing is fantastic on
fungi and so
yeah i mean he's such a great guy he's a
fascinating character fascinating
character i've never met him but
fascinating guy you should meet him and
go
go for a walk with him he was originally
a botanist so he knows everything just
to go for a walk with him outside is
wonderful so let's leave it there
okay all right go for a walk with with
rupert all right on the list thank you
yeah okay so how did we get on to
sweet potato washing in the first place
yeah you asked why the japanese have a
field site in congo which is a great
question
yes because when i'm looking at for
instance the network of play
interactions in wambabanobos and i'm
looking at the names right and it's like
natsuko yukiko
kyota
right there
or in the very beginning we talked about
jiro i think it was yeah and that is
most certainly a japanese name
completely like jiro dreams of sushi
same same
super super fascinating i love
hearing the names of the e1 bonobo group
have pronounced properly
yeah they have some good names he brings
me back there kiku hoshi yeah they've
got some good names yeah
i will ask about
where you think humans are getting it
wrong or maybe making mistakes when it
comes to
sex play
gender i am gonna ask you about that but
i'm planting a seed so that it'll just
gestate for a little while but first
let's talk about
or rather let me ask you about and i
just saw it pop up here the adaptive
joker hypothesis
what is that
that is the name i gave to
to my theory on play behavior
basically
i did for my masters and for my phd i
studied play behavior
and
the question you ask yourself as a as a
revolutionary biologist as mythology is
that what's the function of behavior
and so play has typically
and continues to
very rightly thought as
developmental scaffolding namely
something a behavior that is expensive
and risky but young animals do
in order to build up
the organism so play prepares you for
the future play train skills
all of that is true play fighting in
leopards or something like that play
fighting in leopards uh wordplay in
young humans and as a rule of thumb you
will observe how the young of a certain
species play and you can have inferences
on you know what they do as adults and
you know place training for adulthood so
all of that is true
but if you think of the word scaffolding
to me was puzzling because it's like
developmental scaffolding so maybe it's
because i come from a family of
architects but i keep thinking
a scaffold is something that is used to
build a building and then when the
building is done you remove the scaffold
this couple is useless it's just
aiding you in constructing something and
when the thing the building is ready you
take the scaffold away
and
the object is the thing i the building
that is ready and if play is a scaffold
for building adult organisms it means
that play should finish when somatic
growth finishes
i you turn 17 18 you stop playing
i think again this is roughly true in
many species
it's not very common that adult
animals
play
but if you start looking around again
with this
question of like
hon ask the question and
then tell me which animals play as
adults and so what would come to mind
let me ask you that question
which animals played
yeah dolphins would come to mind yeah
although i do say
what was that second one humans oh i
thought you said cubans i was like maybe
cubans yeah sure
they do like salsa i mean that kind of
looks like damn i mean that's that's
that's playful yes yeah great music
uh i'm sitting in austin texas there's
actually a lot of a lot of amazing
cubans here which is why maybe that's
like talking about the sort of attention
bias
but
humans
although
i mean
one would need to i think perhaps take a
second to define play
so if play is not this
i can't remember the the exact modifier
used but the scaffolding if it is not
that
then then what is play right it seems
like something that doesn't serve an
obvious
functional purpose
that entails some degree of positive
emotional display i mean because i don't
know if that's me struggling for a
definition but no you're correct how
would you define it we're mixing two
definitions there so i want to make a
distinction when you ask this question
tim bergen another famous ethologist
defined the four questions
when you think about a behavior what
why
and from where so
the question i was asking is what's the
evolutionary function of the behavior
which is different from defining it how
does it look today okay right sure so if
you want to define it and when you
observe something and you want to study
it you need to define it
how does it look today so you can define
it broadly as
a behavior that appears cooperative in
the sense that
it doesn't look
forced animals are not doing it under
constrained duress or obvious aggression
and there might be a sense of enjoyment
and it appears not having an obvious
purpose it has repetitive elements but
these repetitive elements also have
variation
and so the element of enjoyment and
recombination of elements is part of it
okay okay
yeah that makes sense and so appearing
to having fun but of course you know
that's easy when you look at humans but
like you look at reptiles and like how
do you know that snake is having fun
it's like well
yeah i don't have
a deep exposure to a lot of animals i
would say canids certainly you see
something resembling play in dogs in
fox
etc yeah wolves certainly
you know cats i mean there seems to be
some type of
tailing off in almost every species i
think of in terms of play i mean maybe
you have like old old
dudes you know like seven-year-old
humans playing chess and
parks and so on but the types of play
changed certainly over time you know one
of the coolest things i've ever seen
was video captured by a trail camera in
the us of a coyote
playing with
i mean i it certainly looked like play
with a badger yes i remember that
they hunt together
and it was jumping around wagging its
tail dropping into kind of this downward
dog like play position just as a
domestic dog domesticated dog would
and i don't want to take us too far off
track but this
this is directly mapping from some
northern american
indian
mythologies or what were thought to be
mythologies that had
largely never been
observed by sort of western
field biologists it was kind of thought
to be this nonsensical
mythology and then lo and behold
it's actually right there in front of
you on camera it's pretty cool but i i'd
never
observed i don't think i'd observed much
in terms of
non-combative inter-species
play in that way right like a cat
playing with a mouse but the mouse isn't
having a great time sure no that would
be there's one animal there having fun
and playing the other one is not
so yeah yeah very clearly so okay so so
those are a few examples that come to
mind yeah what other examples come to
mind for you it's a family of corvids so
ravens crows
are
very playful birds parrots as well
it's not a coincidence if you look at
brain to body size ratio
both these groups of birds by namely
parrots and corvettes are kind of
equivalent if you will
two citations on great apes in their
their big brains cetaceans including
dolphins yeah dolphins of whales so in
that these are animals that
don't think of immediate
genealogical relationships but think of
the niche again what niche what what do
these animals have in common they are
highly social they live in complex
societies they have to deal with
complexity they tend to be long-lived
and just if you add the dimension of
time if you're social and are long-lived
it means you have to deal with
uncertainty
because who's your friend will that be
your friend two weeks from now you
haven't seen them with whom to cooperate
with whom not to cooperate
social life is complex
and so
all of these groups of animals have
these things and common elephants is
another group of animals that also play
and they
fall in this broad group of
generally speaking large brain
intelligent
animals that live for a long time they
are
very innovative but also extremely
social so you have a relationship
between sociality and intelligence and i
think the the third element there is
that play when it's possible because now
we get into the socioecology of play
play is not always possible
particularly for adults many things need
to happen for play to make sense play
has costs and risks
and is more important for the young so
the scaffolding is still true but my
question was like why do you see this
behavior in adult animals
where it's risky and expensive in time
and energy
and
this brings us to you asked me about my
personal conclusions i've been thinking
a lot team about
time budgets and energy budgets
at a personal
level i think
because you are mr optimization
yeah sometimes
yeah well
[Laughter]
actually time budgets you're all about
time budgets namely how you organize
your time right okay can i actually tell
you something what a friend
said yesterday was very funny i follow i
mean i'm part of a literary club in
i attend a workshop every every week
here in chilean you know we are
latin and it's a country of poets and
we have i'm coming from
that explanation of like the latin
poetry tradition
sure
and i told them and we were going to
speak to them and they said oh yeah
i know that guy
i studied him with my son because he has
a method for only working one hour a
week
and then in a very kind of latin poet
yeah i thought it was interesting
i was initially
compelled by this idea of working less
but then i thought he works a lot in
order to work less
the paradox we live in paradox yes
ladies and gentlemen but basically yeah
time budget so actually that led us to a
very interesting discussion on the use
of time and what is to optimize and not
to optimize sure and play behavior i
think has several insights in in that
use of time and use of energy and at
what level do you
put the optimization goal but that's
that's another topic
i have some thoughts on this in a sense
and i should point out for people who
are not aware
most listeners will recognize the name
pablo neruda but
some may not associate
neruda with chile and so chile has this
incredible literary tradition
of course that's only one example but
i would say
part of why play fascinates me and then
i want to come back to like what worries
you about
humans right now right based on
what could we use more of what would you
encourage people to perhaps think about
that could take
any number of different forms right so
i'd love to hear you speak to that but i
will say that
play is very interesting to me because i
think
it overlaps with what we might describe
as flow states quite a lot
and
certainly if we include sports in play
although sports can become very violent
in some cases
but if we include that then
i find that there is
time is a construct right we don't have
time to get into that right now which is
intended pun but for those interested in
getting into the really strange aspects
of kind of time space as a user
interface listen to my conversation with
donald hoffman but
not every hour is created equal right
you can have the experience of passing
an hour
sitting at an airport waiting for
something and it seems like 10 hours you
can have the experience of
being stuck in your inbox and doing
various types of work and the entire day
passes and you can't remember a single
thing that you accomplished
and then you can have this this time
dilation when you play where you're kind
of getting more hours per hour if that
makes any sense
like the perception of time changes
in my experience part of my reason for
being so interested in plays you can buy
you can kind of buy more time
from a perceptual perspective
completely i i think the
your point of the overlap with flow
states is correct
i think play is broader than that flow
states are a sub category
of of play but certainly i think they're
best understood through the lens of play
flow states are perhaps more goal
oriented than
than play necessarily is on the play
if you distinguish between playing games
games are typically more goal oriented
have clear outcomes so a contest
obviously has an outcome and say if you
just like played
fighting with words or dancing but
the reward is the activity itself it's
intrinsic reward so i would draw that
distinction
yeah so what can we learn from what
you've observed in the natural world
maybe what you've studied of of earlier
human civilizations or
ways of organizing ways of playing
and why is it important i know that's a
huge question but i'm just thinking of
the people who are listening to this
podcast and this is you can speak to me
as if you're giving me the advice
because i would like to hear it too and
if it makes you
twitchy to think of it as advice you can
just sort of
describe it as an observer slash
adventure scientist
a lot of people listening to this
are probably listening to this podcast
by and large to
certainly learn
from disparate fields and and different
types of experts but also
they probably work a fair amount i i
would imagine most people who listen to
this podcast work a fair amount and if
you were to give them two glasses of
wine and ask them if they if they would
like more play in their lives they'd be
like yeah for sure for sure and then
that's saturday night they get back to
monday and that conversation disappears
and is long forgotten right so
yeah what do we do yeah so that makes
sense and okay i think let me think
i would say
as an animal
and i say this i think hopefully by now
you realize that i say this in the best
possible way
you have you're constrained first by two
things so i want you to think about your
energy budget and your time budget
your energy budget is for you basically
your financial budget so i think you
obviously have covered this extensively
on you know how to manage and create and
energy budgets i define energy in the
physics way of energy ability to do work
so for organisms energy available is it
comes in the form of
metabolic energy for humans i think a
good proxy is financial energy
financial energy can increase you can
win the notary and you can follow team's
advice and earn more money
right
so god save us good luck everybody all
right
so that's a great thing because thanks
to people like team actually that you
can increase your energy budget
fantastic your time budget however you
can't
time is an incredibly
democratizing force because you
and an earthworm have 24 hours in the
day
so that's a fixed budget which means
that there's this constant interplay
you know tango or martial art if you
want between your energy budget and your
time budget
how you buy time or you use time is in
interaction with your energy budget the
most obvious thing is that if you
increase your energy budget i you have
more money you can buy your time
right so the first observation that i
had with bonobos was that kind of
socioecological question when they have
more wealth i there's more fruit
what will they invested in it's kind of
an investment question
because they could become fatter for
instance namely storing that metabolic
energy right
or they could spend it in grooming
conversation so to say for numbers it
was really interesting to me to see that
in terms of investment
decision but was when there was more
fruit they played more
which tells you several things the first
one is that play is expensive not always
you can play that's fine you know you
first of all you should have sufficient
metabolic energy to eat and travel and
feed your kids and so on play is in that
sense especially for adults it's true
that it's a luxury but here we come into
the adaptive joker hypothesis there are
some things in nature and in human
cultures that when you can afford them
they create more luxury
oh investment in education
living in a city like austin
or new york
i in places that might be expensive to
live but you are putting yourself in a
particular ecosystem that feeds into you
the possibility of creating something
further
the development of the human brain is
another
example something that is very expensive
to grow
but if you can afford it it also affords
new possibilities so what i'm trying to
say that is i think that frame of
thinking where you're trading off time
budgets and energy budgets
i mean any investor would know this but
at
a personal level it has helped me to
look at it much more clearly
because your time is fixed but your
income can grow and so how do you become
like an adapted animal
changing
your time budget accordingly
not only to your income but also to your
context context is the context stupid
right paraphrasing bill clinton
obviously it's economy stupid but it's
the context context is incredibly
important in the sense so i think
there are ways that you can describe
your context how much risk is there how
much uncertainty is there so i think if
there's a lot of uncertainty
you can actually develop ways to become
more flexible
that's what i was trying to study with
the adaptive joker hypothesis what is a
joker in cards joker is the card that
adopts the value of the moment right
it's a trump card
but that value is given by context which
means that play is making you very
good at reading context it's really all
about assessing context so and then it
changes it grows it decreases it becomes
more intense less intense more
aggressive less aggressive what do you
see what i'm trying to say i think i do
could you give an example of that
so for example
ways of playing change form
like a joker
shapeshifts the name comes from it's a
pretend behavior it's a shape-shifting
behavior according to what's happening
so
today after the pandemic well sorry
we're still not after the pandemic but
we're kind of entering that let's face
it largely yeah hopefully fingers
crossed yes
i think ways of playing that are
increasing in frequency are
obviously face-to-face play there's a
hunger for in-person irl in real life
events right you go like well it's kind
of obvious
but
it's not obvious if you will we have
amazing technology we you know the
entire world has learned to zoom
why are we actually willing to still
travel
long distances and pay for plane tickets
and suffer ridiculous cues and stuff
like going to burning man
because this kind of play is important
we have this necessity for in real life
meetings
direct
contact for humans is a very important
form of place not the only form of play
so that would be a very obvious example
that i think i might predict it will we
will see a lot of demand
for that you said earlier if i may
interject that you've only recently
started
implementing or applying
some of these
learnings related to play into your own
life so how have you
applied
these to your own life or what are some
ways that you explore play
the literary workshop is one so
i do this weekly my teacher is called
mathias rivas he's an editor and a poet
and that kind of intellectual play
allowing myself to like oh we i will
spend time not only in science stuff but
actually actively pursuing
artistic
endeavors has been
i think really life-changing and i had
to kind of learn my own lesson well
guess what play is important
at so many levels literature
has become i mean it was when i was a
child
but i had kind of
left it i think it's useful if you think
of the ways you played as a child
there's something very true there
some people some play people talk about
this i
look at your pictures
what were you drawn
what kind of play did you do was it
literary play was it play with animals
social play play fighting construction
play people that did legos i think
there's a deep truth on personal
development that has to do with
what are we drawn in our kind of purest
forms of play so to say
and so to recover that i think it's like
lesson number one
let me jump back to bonobos for a second
i had had a book recommended to me i
can't remember the book nor the author
i'm a bit embarrassed about that but it
related to
chimpanzees and it was the story of a
particular i want to say zoologist who
had taught this is going to be very
broad strokes a particular chimpanzee
something like
200 signs from american sign language
and that chimpanzee then had offspring
and taught the offspring something like
70 or 80
signs so it was a language it was a
vocabulary
really i guess a language more than just
vocabulary that was passed
from this chimp to offspring and it was
the story of this was it pampanisha
uh it might have been it might have been
i'm blanking on the name
yeah
no in this case it was a chimpanzee oh
okay but
the question that came to mind for me
was because i've become very interested
in animal
communication not necessarily people are
like horse whisperers and so on although
that is also interesting to me it's it's
more so animal to animal communication
right so within a wolf pack how do they
communicate
let's say
birds in flight how do they maintain
formation when they're actually
taking
micro sleeps and the way that they
rotate through this form i mean the
whole thing is just incredible but how
do they communicate if they communicate
or how do they know
if they don't communicate for instance
right a lot of these types of questions
and so i was looking at this book
summary and i thought to myself
i wonder if this is a step up for the
chimpanzee or a step down for the
chimpanzee to have this like surrogate
language in other words is it an
augmentation or is it replacing
something that actually has
much more subtlety and nuance to it and
so i
i know this is a big shift to gears but
it could affect how one looks at the
play they choose to engage in
how how do bonobos communicate and how
nuanced is their communication right is
it just like four or five
10 or 12 different kind of screeches and
grunts that they get the rough just
across with has that been
in any way distilled
or
identified by field biologists
thank you we are learning obviously and
we're still learning and a lot more will
come but
the first thing that i think is very
important to know is that communication
is multimodal
so
it's comprised of gestures hand gestures
but also body language posture
proximity you are sitting next to whom
you are in which location just the
physical location is also a part of
communication it's also vocal they're
utterances
they utterances have different meanings
and they sometimes can be
combined in different ways i their
communication
is flexible it's not their vocal
communication is not as obviously
flexible as human languages we have
really taken vocal communication to an
extreme but so we have vocal we have
hand gestures we have body language and
other cues smell is also important
so
if you take this as a whole they have
different meanings depending how you
combine it the other thing that is
important to understand i think in
relation to your question and the
chimpanzee example
is that it's very difficult for us as
humans given that we exist in language
to not define
intelligent communication from a human
perspective i
given that i do language how good are
you at doing language oh
language i spoken word right
if you're not as good as doing language
it means that your communication is
inferior so
you know you're defining the ability to
swim if you're a fish
right according to how you swim so
i mean
that is kind of a little bit inevitable
perhaps but i think today we try to
think of it
from the point of view of the animals in
relation to the problems they have to
solve and in relation to the environment
they are in notice oh can they solve
puzzles because we are so good at
solving puzzles
so
that's in general terms another thing
that i think is important to think
when you think about animal
communication
is
again their environment bonobos live in
the jungle
one of the obvious problems when you're
in the jungle is that there's a lot of
trees
so seeing visual cues
are
sometimes difficult
i learned if you talk to birders
you are birding in a forest
you start
listening basically you word
by listening to calls not not by
visually recognizing and i realized that
i started i shifted perceptual modes so
to say
i started like i was following play
and i would get super attuned to
kind of
how can i say this
kind of it would sound weird but a
temperature which is i call it a
temperature but it's really a
combination of things like the time of
day
the place
where you your body knows what's likely
to happen
and then
auditory cues
namely laughter
very distant
and then you follow that and then you
see them the reason i mentioned that is
because it gave me a very obvious
insight into bonobo communication namely
they can't always see each other
therefore auditory communication is
important
yeah yeah i've only recently really
really come to appreciate how
discreet different animal calls can be
and you know i hesitate to use the word
nuanced because i'm not really sure in
this context what that would mean but
for instance
you can train your ear to identify say a
wildebeest alarm call for a lion versus
a leopard they sound different yeah or a
squirrel alarm call for certain types of
predators that are stationary versus
same predator when it's moving correct
right so there's
even for animals we would consider
perhaps very
again this is kind of anthropomorphizing
and judging them by our capabilities but
simple
i still have a wide range of ability to
communicate
and
i i have to imagine that we've only
scratched the surface i know there's
been some very interesting research done
with dolphins
but
if we could talk about this for hours
and hours and hours which we won't but
if you had to hazard
some theories
that you think are worth
examining
say over the next
5 10 20 years maybe we'll have more
technology that will assist in this but
as as it relates to
field biology and animal communication
do you have any
theories you'd like to
posit as as worth exploring or
do you think there are any insights that
perhaps you've observed
not insights any phenomena that you've
observed that you think well this isn't
really something i can
i wouldn't go so far as to say
this exists and i've proven it exists
but there there is a hypothesis
kind of worth disproving here that
that is interesting
does anything come to mind for you
many things which are mostly questions
following bonobos in the jungle
we try to predict their daily movements
i just the question where are they going
and why
and we couldn't
we couldn't not even the most
experienced trackers because we wanted
to know where they were going for a very
practical reason because that would
allow us to sleep for longer and find
them
right
and we couldn't and they seemed so the
mental maps in their heads their
cognition
how do they know where to forage it's a
very basic question
and a lot of animal behavior people with
a particular species have very good
answers about this whether you're
talking about migratory birds amazing i
mean migratory birds how do they know
have you seen the distances that these
birds travel
little guys i mean it's amazing yeah
it's bananas then the world of cetaceans
and
or bats austin and batson ecolocation
another huge topic but
to stick with bonobos
in the jungle the jungle is in many ways
like the sea in the sense of that this
particular jungle is flat you don't have
perspective not like chilean forest
where you're in the mountains and you
can see far
so
you are embed from my own perspective i
was like this is just like a sea of
green
obviously i'm not attuned to the nuances
that they are a tune also because it's
not
tempered
and environment but tropical the
fruiting patterns it's kind of weird
some trees fruit once a year some drinks
every two years some trees you go i
don't know a few months so what i'm
trying to say that the environmental
uncertainty the fluctuation
in fruiting patterns
is
to my human and train i
very large and they seem to have this
map that
basically they know they know where
when the boom bamboo tree has ripe fruit
they were like okay we're shifting
across the whole territory and i'm like
how do they know
these basic questions about travel i i
find them fascinating but maybe that was
my own like gig
thing because i look at gps endlessly so
i haven't worked it out yet
that's one answer yeah but that is
actually
compounded by
actually um the second part of the
answer to your previous question about
play in my personal life
for the pandemic i was in chile
and i discovered not only like this old
way of
literary play
but also started
again and being a lot more spending a
lot more time in the mountains
and so that is that opens an entirely
new chapter in terms of physical
exertion and and risk and
you know i'm i'm not like a martial arts
guy so
but still i you know i like to well you
and i both know jason niemer the
co-founder of acura yoga so you you have
no excuse not to do acro
i'm gonna try to get out of it as much
as i can
which is probably i mean one of the most
similar forms of play if we map between
sort of bonobos and chimps and humans
right yes i mean that would seem to be
i'm not going to say completely but copy
and pasted from
from these primates completely it
definitely seems to scratch some type of
itch i mean i've never
with the exception of maybe some weird
injury never
had an acroyoga session where i'm like
wow i really wish i hadn't done that
session like you always feel better
afterwards
checks so many boxes so i want to give
him credit jason where credit is due
since he's the one who who also
introduced us totally you know to come
back to that travel question
or how they know where to forage there
are two things come to mind for me one
that is equally mysterious
in some respects which is a story told
in a book called of wolves in men
by barry lopez which is a spectacular
book
and he talks about
traveling with field biologists and at
multiple points observing
say a wolf pack that would
get up point in one direction and just
head off and they would
trek for
this is in deep snow too i mean this is
calorically energetically expensive
right this decision has consequences
and
they would travel for multiple days and
then intersect perfectly with a
migrating caribou herd that happened to
be
traveling sort of the opposite side of
this triangle and you just have to ask
yourself okay
how does that happen exactly and there
are you know maybe it's a seasonal thing
maybe the caribou are doing that
constantly so it's really just like
intersecting with a highway although by
the story in the description it didn't
seem to be the case
i find it very exciting that there are
so many open questions right because
it seems like at every point in
human history we more or less thought we
had it all figured out i mean this is
true during like the you know
alexandrian periods this is true
with the egyptians it's true for
hunter-gatherers i mean by and large
like we had to figure it out maybe our
explanatory model was
gods and this and that the other thing
but one has to assume that as one doctor
said to me
fifty percent of what we know is wrong
we just don't know which fifty percent
the other hypothesis that comes to mind
as you're talking about
bonobos and forging behavior and we
don't have to get into this but people
should look it up on wikipedia at the
very least
is i believe it's called the drunken
monkey hypothesis and the drunken monkey
hypothesis
is a hypothesis that
humans are predisposed to
alcoholism and ethanol abuse because
we were rewarded for being highly
attuned
from an evolutionary perspective
to fermenting
fruit and
that that was one
olfactory cue that we used to locate
food sources and
that that is
one partial
explanation or maybe complete
explanation for why we are so
predisposed to alcoholism as humans
which i thought was pretty interesting i
haven't i haven't gone too deeply into
it but it
at face value seems to make some sense
to me
and
i know we have gone a lot longer than
planned
dr isabelle so i want to be respectful
of your time and also i think both of us
probably need a little bit
speaking of
something calorically expensive this
conversation i think
was probably calorically expensive so we
could use some food and blood glucose
but uh is there anything and we'll do
around two at some point this has been
so much fun and i didn't get i i didn't
even get through five percent of the
notes i have in front of me so
we have no shortage of things to discuss
is there anything that you would like to
mention
before we
come to a close for this round one
people can find you online on twitter at
isabelle benkei
b-e-h-n-c-k-e we'll link to that in the
show notes instagram.com forward slash
isabel underscore benkei
and we will include all these in the
show notes at tim.blog
podcast with links to all the resources
mentioned
anything else that you would like to
bring up any other comments complaints
requests of my audience anything at all
before we
bring this to a close
thank you tim
two things one the comment on on the
instagram and twitter
it's basically i love feedback
because i think nature evolves through
feedback
i'm not very big on twitter i think i've
been publishing more in instagram
mainly through a form of play because i
discovered for myself that taking
pictures is fun so they're not
necessarily great but
it's a it's a way of playing so anyway
if anyone wants to kind of interact
there that's uh and i welcome the good
bad and the ugly so that's fun for me i
love to learn
and then the second point was in
relation to your coming about the
drunken monkey hypothesis
i do think it's a partial explanation
because as you will know by now my bias
is to go back to origins and take you a
little bit
further back in time
the reason why we have asked yourself
why would we have the machinery
for being drawn to fermentation in the
first place
think about that i think the answer of
that is play
because play is about the machinery
for a kind of
biological excitement
and intensity seeking
and so the overlap
of abuse substance abuse but also
creativity and risk-taking
i think a lot of these reward mechanisms
are linked and this is a huge topic and
it's complicated because we go both on
the light side and the dark side
of things like creativity which
should not be spoken lightly but let me
just leave that maybe for the next time
we'll save that for chapter two and for
people who
you bring up a great point actually
which is i mean many great points but
the assumption that our ancestors sought
out fermented fruit as a food source may
be
off base
because there are tons of animals
or solely as a food source might be
misplaced because if you look at
many different species throughout
the
animal kingdom
you find examples of seeking inebriation
right you find
tons tons all over the place so you know
reindeer and lapland like to have fun
too people can look up that story in the
origins of santa claus if you want some
extra credit reading but uh isabel benke
so nice to see you it is
so lovely to spend time together
guys to have a chance to explore all
these things you have so many other
stories you have so many other interests
we didn't even get to your photographing
of dead animals
i'm gonna leave that as a teaser
there are so many
so many interesting side alleys to take
and we will share we will share that
with with everyone in round two at some
point but thank you so much for taking
the time
lovely thank you so much for leading
such a wonderful dance
hasta la proxima and for everybody
listening thank you so much for tuning
in until next time be a little kinder
than is necessary and take care
gracias
you